we love each other so much and like we
love being around each other and we're
super good friends I guess for now it's
just the best that we stay that way so
like looking back on it it's like
literally so bizarre to me to even think
this is possible from a nap when I first
Jelena to talk it was kind of as a joke
I think that's kind of what everyone
Dallin to does but I was babysitting a
lot of like middle schoolers at the time
and they all had Tech Talk and that was
kind of like the age group that used
that at the time and I ended up getting
it just just because they all had it and
I posted a video as a joke and it
actually did really well and I was like
very shocked and um after that point it
was kind of like realizing like oh my
gosh like you can actually like get
somewhere with this app I never would
have thought I'd be here just from
posting those videos like I can't even
believe I even live in California let
alone Los Angeles like it's so crazy for
me that I came from Louisiana which is
like so small and like I was literally
there six months ago six months ago I
live there and even like I just moved
here in December my true friends that
I've like had with me for a really long
time are so supportive of me and like
don't treat me excuse me don't treat me
any differently like they still treat me
the same and with also with like
congratulating me and supporting me
through it but they're all like very
solid people that are in my life still
and I feel like a lot of people think
like when this happens to people like
out of nowhere like they just kind of
like lose the connections with their old
friends but like my best friends that
I've had forever it's just like we still
talk every day and like it hasn't
changed a thing they just are super
supportive and proud of me
no CC so my family is so supportive of
me like luckily not everyone gets
blessed with the supportive family but
my family has been so supportive and my
mom actually my dad too
with my mom she has a million followers
on the app on tik-tok so yeah she's
almost at two millions it's pretty crazy
because actually we like blew up
together luckily that happened and we
our first video that we did together
like did really well together and we
ended up making a couple more and we did
one to Mariah Carey's song why soap says
with me and she liked it and it was like
so crazy because that was like right
when I started tick-tock I think I maybe
had like 50 to 75k and she liked it and
then we started making more content
together me my mom and then that was
actually my first video to hit a million
likes with my mom all my videos prepare
like do so well because people like love
to see a mom and daughter duo you know
whenever you tell me I'm pretty that's
some hunger really hits me your heart
goes pitter-patter I do sometimes
I'm such a people person it's like
anytime I get to meet someone I'm like
super eager but um I guess you could say
like it is scary to think about the bad
side of things like when you do hear
about like celebrities or like even just
people that are like I don't know just
like more in danger I guess you could
say like people are like there are
people in this world that aren't good
and like I think for me it's like taking
a lot of realizing that to like know
like I do have to be more reserved on
that side because not everyone is out
just to support me like you know some
people are are jealous people or like
some people have bad intentions or like
just don't have a good heart and like do
you want to hurt people and I think for
me like right now it's like obviously
hard for me to wrap my head around it
because I'm not used to that stupid
boarding
like changes season no you you think I'm
cute decimal yes okay we are just
friends um so it kind of just we
actually met in October and uh we
started hanging out a lot it was kind of
like we weren't even really friends I
would say like we were just kind of
around the same people a lot more
acquaintances I guess you could say and
um and then later into like October we
ended up just hanging out a lot and like
when I was coming back and forth to LA
like I didn't live here I was coming
back like Halloween and like my birthday
and stuff like that we kind of started
hanging out more and then like once I
moved here we like started hanging out a
lot and then we got like super close and
like we were really really really good
friends no we we were we were talking
and like kind of on and off just like
trying to figure things out and like I'm
also like like I said very new to this
and like he's been in this industry for
a really long time but um you know
things happen and then like we just
decided like we're better off as friends
for now because like we both have like
totally different I guess like
lifestyles right now not necessarily
just like apart from the social media
just kind of like we both are like
looking to branch off to different
things and like do different things so I
think right now we're just better off as
friends and like we both like mutually
decided that like it was kind of just a
thing that we were like you know we love
each other so much and like we love
being around each other we're super good
friends so it's like for I guess for now
it's just the best that we stay that way
and like you know we support each other
100%
I don't know you know like I I don't
really have any plans for my future just
because life does change so fast and I
feel like when you try to plan things
out things never work out so right now
I'm kind of just going with the flow and
who knows what will happen
[Music]
yes like that's so crazy to think about
I mean I think it's so cool like I love
that because that's like I mean I'm a
fan girl like for sure like when I see
like anybody I'm like oh my gosh that's
that's Bobo like oh my gosh I love them
so much and so like I think I kind of
like can put myself in that position and
be like I was always so interested in
everyone's live because it's just so
much fun to like see that I guess you
kind of like lift through people in that
way you know like I'm like watching the
Kardashians and I'm like oh my gosh I
want to know what's happening here
because like I wonder what I'd be like
to experience that yeah yeah they're um
so I'd say there's not really rules it's
kind of just like a okay be careful of
this because like we don't want people
to get the wrong idea so like sometimes
I guess with collaborations it could be
like that possibly but I feel like you
don't really let it control you as far
as like deciding if you're gonna do
something or not because like no matter
what when the end today comes you know
you know who you like or like what's
going on so like you don't really like
to determine your post you kind of just
are a little more careful I guess you
could say
but regardless like people are always
gonna like like to see people together
like see people good they're so cute
together you know we all like gate
weaving it's funny I like serious
relationships Anna a girl like me don't
stay single for
I do like being on my own I actually was
in a really really long serious
relationship before any of this happened
to me yeah so um I've learned a lot from
that relationship and it was a really
big part of my life for about five years
so it was just like it was um different
to like branch off to this and so now
that I am in this position it's just
like me time you know like I spent a lot
of my time in a relationship so it's
like now is my time to grow and like
chase my dreams on my own and it's kind
of what I'm doing we kind of just cut
ties after I ended up graduating high
school and I mean I'm sure he's I'm sure
he knows what's going on but I don't
really know I love her because like
oceans are so good to me and I literally
with this into it like cry like when I'd
get into my feelings I was listening to
ocean ice but um and then like as she
got more popular I kind of like I was
like oh like I loved her music but I was
like oh she's she's mainstream like
everybody listens to her now so it's not
as cool you know when you find that
artist and then they block I'm like dang
it like I want to interview mine but um
no and I still like supported her
obviously through like her big blowup
and like everything that went on and
then just recently I saw her at the
Spotify event and I was like like alive
and I was like that's the first time I
ever saw her live and I was like oh my
gosh like she's an angel I didn't meet
her but I literally was I was like
screaming I was like I love you every
time I music good fluid
I like she's just she's insane she's
incredible
I hope so I don't know if she does
that'd be so awesome I think and not
even for the like filming part purposes
of it you know just like to meet her and
she's done so much at her age and it's
just so inspiring they like see that and
like know that that's so possible and
like where she came from like her story
is incredible so I think just even being
around her is like wow like she she did
this on her own and like here she is in
the next year I really am pushing to get
into acting really hard right now so
I've been on a lot of auditions and like
castings and stuff like that so
hopefully in the next year I'll be
casted in a movie or TV show which would
be so insane because that's kind of like
always been my dream just like be on the
big screen stranger things would be
really cool in everyone but honestly
anything at this point
I like think all movies are so awesome
and it's just kind of like exciting to
even be in this time where I can do
those things you know like I can't even
believe it's possible for me right now
so any chance that I get
I'd be so open to and then in the next
five years I um I hope to be like
financially able to support myself and
my family that'd be super awesome to
gonna do and I think as far as like
career-wise I think just like being the
best at what I would I get into and what
I do would be the goal I think everybody
sees like pretty much every part of me
cuz I'm I am like very real on the
internet and like I don't know I'm a
very positive person naturally and I I
think actually that could be one some
people think like I smile too much or
like I'm too happy they're like
something must be wrong I'm like no like
I just am positive I guess like I've
learned like growing up I've been
through a lot too and I think like you
know you live and you learn that like no
matter what if you like are smiling and
positive about situations it does make
you feel better about it and I think
like that's a big thing for me is like
spreading positivity and like love and
happiness and it's like that when you
put those things in out into the world
like that always comes back to you
I think she says like as far as like
relationships in like high school and
like in middle school in high school I
kind of like people who obviously are
mean there are people that are trying to
tear you down and I think like going
through that and just like hearing
people it's negative or it's kind of
like changed me into the way it's like I
can only control how I feel about what
they say about me and like now to this
day it's like helped me a lot with like
hate and stuff like that just to like be
more positive about it and realize like
just because someone's having a bad day
or like maybe feeling insecure about
themselves doesn't mean you have to let
that affect you oh for sure yeah if
people are bullies sometimes but on
tik-tok it's like a whole nother level
like people just aren't afraid to say
anything behind a screen you know like
they it doesn't really resonate with
them that like you are somebody like it
they just look at you and think oh they
won't see this but everyone else will
see this comment and like for ticked-off
like a lot of times people will try to
get like the top likes comment and like
they'll say something mean and then like
that'll end up being the top so it's
like it is hurtful and like it does
affect you but I think like at the end
of the day it's tough you just you look
back and you're like look where I am and
like where I've got myself and like I'm
so grateful for the people that do love
me and there are so many more people
that support me and love me and like
just aren't afraid to like cheer me up
then like the haters so I feel like it
kind of just you brush it off because
you're like you know like maybe they're
having a bad day I do yeah I read I try
to read the top ones just because they
are like the most sometimes and then I
try to respond like a lot of the
positive comments just so people know
that I still like to read them and like
obviously like love to hear that
I hope your day gets better and somebody
and somebody loves you so if that can
help your day a little bit thank you
[Music]